i
have tried my best
piled under
my stress
but the past i
can't see
when you
were here here with me
[Music]
now it's been so many years
[Music]
and if you'd like to see my disgrace
[Music]
cold from
lack of skin
fighting
[Music]
beneath my fears
[Music]
faces
[Music]
i'm
afraid to say
[Music]
the words you let us stray
i'm expecting to
pursue
[Music]
a bond
that i thought i once knew
when i
was happy
[Music]
[Music]
and if you have an imprint
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i can't wait forever i'm not that
patient i got too many things to do
you're comfy like a sweater but when
this one comes out
[Music]
that is
[Music]
but instead i
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how
[Music]
i can't wait forever
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody
hello
hey i think i saw n trillion earlier i'm
not too sure but hello hello hello kevin
deacon hello ign's cruz
hey mantas what is up gamers
always the same welcome hey rexella
okay let's start off every stream
with a song so
yeah i'm gonna play for you
[Music]
one that a lot of you have already heard
in the past but that i really fancy
playing so we're gonna play it
hope all your weeks have been okay if
not then hope
hopefully you can chill out a bit
tonight at least
hey eb hey frank
franken
[Music]
but he used to be a singer in a rock and
roll band
he would write the songs and i tremble
at his hand
oh
[Music]
and he used to be the life and soul of
everyone around
you'd never catch him looking up but
never see him down but
he couldn't raise a smile oh not for a
while and
he's a failure now
don't
cry
child
[Music]
you've got so much more to live for
don't
cry
child
you've got something i die for and if it
comes
to the right
just be glad you smile again
cause so many
tones
and so many go
unnamed
people pushed right past me shouting
their exclaims a preacher pushes me
aside and asked to wash my sins i said
no
la hola
he's a failure too
and he used to need a couple people keep
my head down
well now i need to hold them all to keep
me on the ground and brutal
oh i gave up something and i gave it for
nothing and now i'm a failure now
[Music]
don't
cry got so much more to live for
don't
cry
child
you've got something i would die for and
if it comes to the rain
just be glad you smile again
so many
don'ts
and so many go
a name
[Music]
hello
the dreaded click break draws me in i'll
be back all right enjoy your clickbait
video
and welcome to the stream
so hopefully that set the mood for what
will be a nice relaxing stream yes ign
relaxing igan chris i don't know how to
say your your username
um but yeah how has everyone's weeks
been
i have been
crazily concocting up so many it's so
annoying because like i want to tell you
what what i'm working on but like
there's like about three different
things that my head's working on but one
of those things is
um sorting out a halloween stream and
very excited for it uh i've got i've
roped in a couple of friends most
friends have plans because it's
halloween and people go outside usually
but if you don't if you're not going
outside at halloween
please please please follow me on
twitter um go on the discord uh i'll get
a quick discord invite now
uh because i will be streaming on the
saturday the 30th
and not too sure the times yet still
working all that out but it should be it
should be a pretty good time i'm quite
excited for it
let me just get you the link come on
let me use
a
[Music]
singer i've been making a load of
progress on the project i'm working on
oh cool what are you working on mantas
you should share it with us on the
discord only when you want to of course
hey attila thank you thank you
cute little star star face
um but yeah we've got
uh there is a new unreal engine music
video in the works um
it's looking good i'm getting the color
palette sorted the 3d models are all
done
getting the colored palette sorted and
then the lighting
and then i'm going to try and
do like a little green screen thing so
it might take a little bit longer but
exciting also it's not really a spooky
thing so i was thinking probably won't
release it until next month anyway but i
have been learning a new spooky song and
i'm going to try and get to the forest
to record it just like old days
yeah because the last time i did that
was like two years ago so just like old
times that would be cute wouldn't it if
i could do that um
but yeah oh nda's stuff are fair enough
well i'm glad you're making progress and
that you feel good in yourself anyway i
felt like that today at work i felt very
progressive
progressive i made much progression
the progress was made
i felt good about it
i don't know if if you ever do this but
i like sometimes when i get in the flow
with work we will get into the game in a
minute i'm really sorry i'm just
rambling um
sometimes when i get in the flow with
work um
you're like you're at your desk or
you're trying to sort out something
and you're like you you know
the tasks that you have to do
and then
i get it done and my subconscious mind
just instantly clicks
the shutdown button on my computer
before i've even realized i've done it i
don't know if anyone else says that but
it's like part of the flow and i think
my brain does it now because it's learnt
that whenever i complete a task i then
consciously make another task so my com
subconscious is like
no
we're done
it just shuts down the computer and then
i realize i've just shut down the
computer and i'm like oh okay it's
probably a good thing so probably to
step away
i don't know if any of you have ever
subconsciously shut down your computer
because you don't want to consciously
make any more tasks but it's a good
habit to develop
hey clay
but yeah i want to be playing some
spooky games on halloween the 30th not
the 31st because it's sunday
um
some songs as well obviously maybe some
other things still trying to figure it
out but definitely playing some games
with my friends as well um probably
phasma phobia i've heard that that's had
quite a few updates so i'm intrigued to
see what those updates are
uh but yeah
look out for
uh updates on that
but for now we're gonna finish life is
strange before we move on to anything
spooky because after life is strange
we'll be playing a lot of spooky games
they'll be like alan wake fatal frame so
let's continue with a nice chill game
before we hop back into the horror game
as usual let me know if you want me to
change anything with the audio should be
okay
um i've already played it uh last i'm
sorry attila i played it um
in my spare time like in my free time so
i won't be streaming that no but i will
be streaming alum wake
and yeah fertile frame so
i'm so excited to play alan wig
mantas because i've heard so much about
it
um
people have been inspired by that game
so yeah i'm very i'm very intrigued and
i don't know too much about it to be
honest so yeah it should be a fun fun
playthrough
come see me when you get the chance oh
yes i remember this this is where we
left off
did i look around the room i don't think
i did i think i just
stopped playing didn't i
so last
time we were
selfish how long have they been watching
us
and what will they do if
no i guess it's not selfish we decided
to take down the man even though it
means
maybe putting ourselves and our loved
ones in danger
but i think it's worth it
i have no idea what to do next
maybe talking to jed will help me feel
better
yeah
it's a little father figure isn't he
first i need to get out of this dress
yes please um
yep
the tables seem to have turned all right
riley probably can't help me hack typhon
oh jeez my phone is going absolutely
mental
this isn't over gabe
i promise
why does she have that letter
your heart oh right yeah shouldn't she
have given that letter back to his
back to charlotte maybe charlotte
doesn't want it
she still hasn't found that puzzle piece
and it's so annoying
i really enjoy
we get a conclusion on this unfinished
puzzle i really hope that like
the the last episode of the game she's
gonna find a puzzle piece and then
it's gonna be a nice ending i guess the
night wasn't all bad
can't wait to have nightmares tonight
i think i'm all played out for tonight
fair enough
maybe i'll just bike out to the mine
dig up some answers myself
okay what i look better than i feel i
don't want to look at this let's uh put
on some different clothes
bye mantas might as well go talk to jed
now
no can i not change
i want to choose what i'm wearing i want
to choose what i'm wearing oh it's the
first time i haven't been able to choose
that's that
okay fine
um i know we got to talk to jeb but can
i go upstairs no i can't okay
feels like the larp was a hundred years
ago
hey chad
there she is
have a seat
something tells me you've had a more
exciting spring festival than you
planned for
you saw pike arrest me
and let you go apparently
then there's that business with ryan and
steph earlier today
i wasn't sure why it took all three of
you to work out diane's lunch order
i know you're used to looking out for
yourself
gabe was like that
but haven't's a community
we help each other
i want to help you
but first
you have to let me know what's going on
[ __ ] it
what have i got to lose
um is the stream quality bad
or is it like normal how come we cannot
subscribe to your channel
what oh twitch i'm not an affiliate
you can uh follow me though
but i'm not i'm not an affiliate so i i
think only affiliates you can subscribe
to
um thank you though for
for going to do that that's very nice of
you i'm just checking the
um the quality of this
stream
because uh you know twitch got hacked
into so i had to update a lot of the
information
um
including the stream key obviously
just so you know if you didn't know
please reset your passwords on twitch um
set up two-factor authentication
uh yeah please do all that looks fine on
twitch looks perfect on twitch not for
me
okay cool
sweet it's good okay good good to know
good to know thank you everyone thank
you
um but yeah thank you so much i think
you can follow me on twitch um which
should let you know when i'm streaming
but if not you can you can always
subscribe on youtube if you want to
[Music]
uh the reason i'm not an affiliate is
because i do stream on both platforms
and if you're an affiliate you can only
stream on one platform it's like a
clause in their fine print or something
i'll double check it but i'm pretty sure
and i can't choose between the two so
i've just never actually become an
affiliate
um
[Music]
take a shot
typhon killed gabe typhon threatened
ryan
um
yeah we'll say this basically typhon
killed gabe
i have proof
sorry daniel didn't do this
i stole it from diane
emails and documents proving there was a
second explosion the night gabe died
to cover something up jed
some
secret they buried
i don't know what it is
i don't even know what to do next
but i'm not giving up
not ever
i know what they're hiding
that's a cute little moat palace
i thought it was a little sloth at first
i don't know what it is but it's cute
uh you knew
i'm just gonna ask
please jed
what's the truth
what are they afraid of
typhon's the devil that runs this town
i've been carrying their secrets for far
too long ah wait
i know what they buried in the mountains
tell me tell us about the mythical
creature the mountains
i'll show you
we're gonna meet the mythical creature
if it's not a mythical creature i'm
gonna be well upset
i want like a dragon or something in
there
there up ahead yeah or aliens if
anything like that
where are we
middle of nowhere
about two clicks that way is the mining
site where you search for ethan five
clicks that way is town
what is this thing
ventilation shaft they're scattered
everywhere
over the years mines grow into mines
creating a labyrinth under haven
what you're searching for is down below
i mean he wouldn't let us go down there
if it was dangerous surely
chad
why are you sad
[Music]
no
fun
[Music]
i'm sorry kid
[Music]
put the gun down
[Music]
just
put the gun down
[Music]
i tried to talk you out of it
scare you off
i was sure those pictures of ryan and
steph would do the trick
but you were relentless
won't leave damn well enough alone
you don't have to do this i do daddy
figure
12 years ago
i made a mistake
the kind of thing that you
you can't undo
what did you do you killed someone but
typhon made me a deal
way to save my town give my boy a normal
life
i never wanted gabe to get hurt
go to hell
[Music]
what
he must have missed
tell me he missed
okay honestly did not see that coming
looking at the chat apparently you did
but i did not i did not see this coming
what the hell
pike let alex go after she removed his
fear okay most people did remove the
fear so it wasn't just us that chose to
do that thing
um
uh
alex gave her rose to staff yeah i
honestly just think they're better
suited i feel like the game wanted us to
be with steph because i mean
our interests are musical steph's
interests in musical we sing up on stage
together it was just set up
to kind of like definitely have some
sort of romantic
thing going on i know she had that um
that little moment where she was looking
at the clouds of ryan but i just don't
think it was enough
uh the game definitely seems to
sway us towards choosing steph that's
just how i thought anyway you might have
thought different um
i had a nice moment behind the bonfire
uh
i did not sit on the couch
oh
i missed that
uh
alex and steph muse about moving to the
ocean oh one of most most people said
that they didn't meet on the rooftop
what
uh
and then they move into
salem stephen alex shared a kiss
hell yeah
ryan didn't meet alex on the rooftop no
ryan didn't meet alex on the rooftop no
did not kiss ryan
alex and charlotte shared a bittersweet
moment in the festival
oh i'm glad we got that one that's 50
50. charlotte felt weirdly detached i'm
glad we didn't get the other one maybe
oh so that's probably what would have
happened if we have taken away her anger
maybe she would have felt weirdly
detached at the festival hello bergie
i really need to get rid of that i've
been nominated thing um thank you for
everyone who voted i find out i think
monday actually
riley went away to college
i really wanted her to go to college but
i just could not not tell her the truth
so
but i'm hoping she'll just go to college
anyway that's what i wanted her to do
maybe not straight away but maybe she'll
go like next year or something i don't
know
accident fine friday of a stop most
people didn't do that 47 didn't find
riley at the bus stop damn
ducky joined the festival yeah yeah yeah
yeah most people didn't use the power
with ducky ducky was sad that ducky
didn't go to the festival oh
that's sad
but we did
um alex helped with the jelly bean
counter yes we did we got those jelly
bean numbers right
um alex didn't talk to dinah bryant what
i thought i talked to everyone where the
hell was diana buyer
alex got the guy and gal friends
together yeah we did
yeah we did okay last chapter i think
last chapter
hey deaf
i'm good thanks how are you
chapter five side b
welcome back alex
do you want to talk about your time in
colorado what the hell where is she
she's wearing the same clothes let's
start with something positive
what did you learn from your visit to
haven springs
well what
i learned to let myself feel
i guess
and to not be afraid of those feelings
couldn't one argue that those old fears
turned out to be justified
what do you make of that friction
[Music]
i suppose i'm proud of you for trying
helped some people
chased a mystery
got to kiss a pretty girl
but alex
you're right back where you started
how
i'm so confused
so she went back you're wrong
to the city i don't belong in here
if that were true alex
you'd know you were talking to an empty
chair
well
okay this game is taking away time
what the [ __ ] yeah
did you have that nightmare are you in a
coma are you in a coma
[Music]
this is heaven
don't know it seems like a weird happen
to me
oh it's all
high is that what i look like
really no
no it's just a cartoon version of you
hey my guitar
knock knock
[Music]
[Music]
the guitar case is talking to us
alex chen
my guitar case has never heard of me
sure
[Music]
huh
[Music]
she's got to be like
knocked out or something and this is all
in her mind
she's still wearing the same clothes
there's no way she would have traveled
back to the city
and not changed her clothes at any point
and also this is wacky
don't belong to dr lynn
no they're definitely part of your mind
see
all in your mind
tuning peg
[Music]
oh yeah we didn't look at our phone
before we died
oh cool
[Music]
i wonder if we can look at our phone now
no yeah see this is all in the head
that's not that's not right and there's
memories here oh cool
okay
one missing patient ancestor alex she
was always scratching at the door trying
to get out but she's declawed so her
capacity to defend for herself is
minimal if spotted please exercise
caution when approaching she will appear
friendly and normal but we've had some
behavioral issues in the past please
help me find my patient i'm starting to
get really worried
how did i even get back here please join
me in welcoming alex chen back to
helping hands we're happy though not
surprised that alex yeah like they
wouldn't say these things it's not
professional to say those types of
things in light of all the recent
excitement now is a good time to remind
helping hands residents that impulses to
leave our institution while
understandable are best resisted
remember the outside world is sharp
toothed and possessed of an insatiable
hunger and you are a soft and slow
you are soft and slow and appetizing why
throw yourself to its mouth throw
yourself instead into mine
okay freaky
gummies and dollar
bomber jacket
they met in seattle a couple of queer
punk rock girls drifting through the
scene looking for comrades
huh
okay
[Music]
hey
ar trans victor i guess that's me case
number five three three two two so i
guess we use that for the
guitar case
emotionally
emotional instability occasional violent
outbreaths hallucinations visual
hallucinations or
oral hallucinations delusional ideation
depression anxiety diagnosis no bloody
clue
oh i guess because she thinks she's
crazy because of her emotion
what
alex experiences a detailed and robust
solution that she is able to read other
people's emotional states and believes
that because of this ability she is
uniquely equipped to help others and
overcome their own emotional trauma
trauma it's difficult to overlook the
irony someone is profoundly
dysfunctional as alex adapting the role
of emotional caretaker had she not been
returned to my care i do not think it
hyperbolic to speculate that her
reckless attempts at fixing her friends
and family would even have gotten
someone hurt
it's my belief that alex's solutions
constitute a threat to her continued
well-being as well as those of others
as such i recommend alex be thrown down
an endless pitch her body shattered
against each juttering board and errant
brick until she is forgotten in the
darkness beneath the world this is in my
professional opinion the most humane
thing we can do for her yeah
[Music]
[Music]
12 years ago i made a mistake
the kind of thing that you
you can't undo
alex
you know that i care about you
with everything that has happened
i just want what's best for you
[Music]
she's gonna have some major trust issues
okay five three three two two
oh that's an interesting take jan dio
maybe this is how she uses her powers on
herself like she's trying to fix herself
subconsciously
maybe
interesting
spent so much time looking after others
that we haven't already looked inwards
oh no
[Music]
three three two two
[Music]
it's still going baggy but
i don't know if you were here for the
big twist
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
it looked like i mean that might just
been her
hitting things on the way down but like
the bullet raised her head
so he did miss
oh my gosh
well isn't that just
very handy
ready rexella you think he mentioned
this
i don't know
well we'll see if you're right we'll see
but i mean i think he definitely thought
she was gonna die because he pushed her
down the mine shaft
um
alex
oh hello she's in heaven now maybe i
don't know gabe
you're dead
so
lots of people are dead alex
most people
where are we
i want to say
a hospital
dr mendes to intensive care
dr mendez to intensive care
yep definitely a hospital
gabe
okay here's what i do know
you are 10 i am 14.
a mother is sick
so is our father
but it's a different kind of sickness
play your part
ow
okay why
i didn't do anything
both of you
dad
behave
alex
go check on your mother
okay
she was right over there
waiting for me
well when you look at everything else
quest like there it is
the painting that taught me that art
sucked sometimes
we couldn't afford a private room
just got lucky i guess
gabe and i used to watch cartoons on
this thing after school
okay so mum was in here for a long time
so
it was something
[Music]
gabe
alex
i need you to listen very carefully
we got some
scary news today
and
i'm going to be spending some time at
the hospital what
mom
are you okay
hush now it's going to be okay
do you understand me
things will be
different
for a little while
but i am going to be okay
we spent so much time in here that i
basically memorized every article
gabe told me it was full of needles
scared me to death
she knew
even then she knew
it was always too hot in this room
okay
uh baggy jed shot us because i think
uh jed's also working with the um oh
geez what the
forgot their name
you know
uh the explosiony people exposurely
miney people
i think he's working with them
he knew something that happened in the
second mine with the second explosion
and then he said that they were gonna
help him cover it up and he did some
things that you can't undo so i'm
guessing he killed someone there and
they
helped him to clean it up so
i guess he's just helping them in return
because
she can't uncover this kind of stuff and
also helping himself if whatever he did
was in that mind so yeah basically
judd's heavily involved look it's the
hot dog man
anyway this is a series
how many nights did dad spend in this
room
sleeping in an uncomfortable chair
and eating vending machine dinners
there's something so weird and scary
about watching your dad cry
hi mom
such a brave girl
how do you ever get so brave is that how
it went
you don't think you missed anything
ow
gabe why
i didn't do anything
both of you
dad
behave
let's do it again
you missed
i something she's remembering it wrong
alex
go check on your mother
okay
okay what have we meant wait
did i miss something
oh there's water there now
okay i'm not gonna bother with any of
this stuff
but there's water no matter how much mom
drank
our throat was always dry
there's nothing else new here is there
we couldn't afford a private room yeah
just got lucky i guess okay
hi mom
get her some water
where did that voice come from
wait what
thank you
you almost never cried
even when you were very small
did you know that
that's been my biggest challenge with
you
how do you take care of someone
who is already
so strong
[Music]
uh
[Music]
no tears
my strong girl
i want you
to make me a promise
your brother
your father
they are going to need you
you have to be strong
but she can also do that
alex
and cry
[Music]
such a brave girl
how do you ever get so brave
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
oh cool
it's halloween
in their own house around the old house
i guess
see they were all quite happy at one
point then
before the mum passed away
was that the last time you talked to her
mom
i
i think so
do you miss her
gabe
what's going on
you're 11 i'm almost 15. dad and i are
time bombs
you keep running
back and forth trying to defuse us both
[Music]
this is going to suck so bad
play your part
so yeah i guess she's having to relive
her traumas to try and work out some
repressed emotions
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there was only ever one thing to do when
they got like this
drown them out and
wait for it to pass
i thought he said that we had we were
like running up and down or something
trying to defuse them and then she's
just gonna be like nope [ __ ] it
in the music
[Music]
so they said their dad was ill i'm
guessing like
is it alcoholism or
[Music]
the morning rain clouds up my window
and i can't see it
it's okay it's just me
but you know that's not how it went down
right
yes
i just wanted to listen to some tunes
[Music]
okay here we go here we go here we go
let me have a look around i want to look
at the pumpkin it was my job to keep the
peace
but no matter what i did
so if i listen again will i just happen
again probably oh so she's made a shine
for her brother
[Music]
that's a lot of stress to put a little
girl under mom and dad had this tv
before they had either of us
gabe had barely used this backpack in
weeks
nobody could get him to go to school
dad's laundry
i always set it here when it was done so
he could find it
at least i managed to hold on to you
shushu
no
qvd cleaning dad's ashtray was not my
favorite job in the world
and i
want to thank you
for giving me the besties
i do i didn't expect that song to be mom
kept every single one we ever got
i am like that i'm a hoarder for cards i
don't know if any of you have it like
barefoot cards and stuff i feel really
bad throwing them away so i have so many
of them just
somewhere
in boxes or suitcases or whatever my job
was to sort them in order of how close
we were to a collections notice
thanks for trying lucky cat
i wanted to be a werewolf that halloween
couldn't afford the costume
[Music]
i can't believe they were ever this
happy
gabe used to steal dad's beer all the
time
it was like
the one thing they didn't fight about
we never really touched these after mom
died
she was such a good cook the sriracha
you never sriracha i mean you can get
take out and put sriracha on it
two cups water for one cup rice
set timer for 30 minutes
do your history homework
serve
almost empty
almost always
hey gabe
i'm leslie halloran i'm from the oregon
state child protective services
we got a call from someone who said
there might have been some kind of fight
here last night
is your dad home
oh gosh you know what we were yeah that
was like uh rehearsal and i'm in this
play at school and my dad like he was um
helping me learn my lines
the most overdone excuse must be some
play
but if you need anything
my number is on there okay
mom's old sewing kit
don't think i've ever even tasted a
butter cookie oh gosh
when wasn't this place falling apart
the killer mistress tabs in this book
weren't even close to right
gabe loved son of lead back when it was
in indy it was too
gory for me
and then it got to mainstream
okay so that's
everything
[Music]
where you going
how are you gonna tell her
or is that my job keep your voice down
fine i'll do it alex dad lost his job
again
so we're broke
again don't talk to me that way
despite what you may believe you do not
know everything
you think what i laid myself off it's
okay we'll figure it out i could um i
don't know dad but what are we supposed
to do now we gotta eat
we can sell some records or or what
about my guitar we can sell that alex
what is it gonna take to get you to stop
defending him your mother could see you
now i don't wanna hear about my babe
i'm so tired of you using her as an
excuse to be a piece of [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] touch me
piece of [ __ ]
damn it alex
i'm okay
it's okay
it was an accident
alexa
i i i didn't dad
dad it's okay
really
i'm not hurt
i can't do this
dad
someone will come
that
woman from cps is he is he just leaving
someone is he just leaving them
dad
i'm sorry
what
the [ __ ] he took that from her too what
the [ __ ]
ah
that's so much to have to go through
uh
oh she tried to
send letters to him and he didn't even
he just returned hey can i ask you a
question
which orphanage is this
the one in grant park
kind of thought it'd be nicer
i can't do this okay i
i can't
you need to
no
you need to be honest about what you see
i was
i have
and now i'm done
almost
but not yet
you were 12 i am 16.
i steal a car and end up in juvie gabe
come on
then you're 13
14
15.
orphanages group homes
musty rooms in the strange houses of
foster parents by the time you're 17
you've seen them all
somewhere along the line
you start to feel things
your own emotions don't belong to you
you have nothing
no one
you are alone
i don't want this
alex
play your part
play my
part um i've just turned up my mic cause
apparently
apparently i wasn't loud enough but let
me know how that sounds
i used to write one every day
why it's not stupid you clearly missed
him yeah and i thought he missed me
hence stupid
no
no you deserved yes i missed a few days
i don't like this message either
happiness is a choice you make every day
i mean fair enough
but also sometimes no i mean there are
literal
uh like psychological reasons why you
would not be happy every day and cannot
be happy every day it's like impossible
and then you shouldn't blame yourself
for not making the choice to be happy
because that just sends you down into a
negative spiral of always blaming
yourself for everything which is not
ever gonna make you happy i just don't
like quotes like that anyway
we were in a lab
we weren't allowed to bring glass into
the dorms
so we had to drink from this thing
like hamsters pretty sure it's locked no
must be after curfew
we're not going anywhere
god
they put me on so many meds
alex chen damn they did
i don't even know what any of this is
well lithium
did any of them work
some of them helped a little
none of them fixed me
in their defense mutant empathy isn't
exactly in the dsm
[Music]
i took a fork in here one time and hit
it under my mattress
just cause
[ __ ] you
uh assign schedules glass and silverware
to remain in the canteen no resident
guests are not mixing the dormitory
lights out because at 9pm every evening
no music no tv no screen time after
lights out
okey dokey
they used to say this place wasn't a
prison
or maybe they were trying to keep you
safe
guess so
whatever the reason
the end result was prison bars
they should have stenciled the same
thing on all of
us oh do you really feel like you were
their property
we didn't belong to anyone else did we
i remember the kid who put this here
sadie
sally
um
something with an s
you were friends at first right
way at first
then i freaked out on her and she was
done with me
just like everyone else
fancy everyone had one good outfit
we wore them to meet the parents
oh did it help teddy i kind of think you
already know the answer to that question
how are you holding up shoe
i can't believe how long you've had that
thing
that thing
was my only friend after you left
i don't understand
why can't i have my guitar
we've been over this alex
your guitar stays in the rec room you
can play it during free time
that's [ __ ]
i don't need it in the [ __ ] rec room
i need it when i'm stuck in the [ __ ]
dorms
alex that's enough
maybe we'll just take away your guitar
privileges entirely if that's what you
prefer you can't do that
i would hate this like even the thought
of being in uni and having to share a
dorm room with another person is hell i
don't know how people share rooms rooms
with other people like your room is your
own personal space i just
don't know and family members a little
bit different still not ideal but
different
but with a stranger
people you don't really know like oh
that's horrible i just
yeah i guess i'm really privileged
because i just can't imagine life
without
my own space or my own place to go to be
alone
okay i guess
yes would riot draw dual reading
wheeling nukes and guitars
i want both all the time
shouldn't look out with the moonlight
the sun come out tomorrow
[ __ ] about a dollar
what
why are people just looking in
oh i can play
that's really creepy what
what is going on
she's been through so much i just don't
know if we're prepared for a
troubled girl
no
potential
oh great yes staring me like i'm a zoo
animal
it says here she is
sensitive
what is that
i wonder why she's never found a home
before
i'm sure she's a sweet girl
but she's not for us she's awfully old
isn't she
this is the kid that's been in all those
fights
right i want to help i i really don't
there's just something
broken
wrong
with her
[Music]
i'm sorry
why
you need to see it
see what
that nobody picked me
nobody picked you
nobody picked you
nobody wanted you
mom died
dad left i bailed
you couldn't keep us together it was my
job to keep it you were 11 years old
you were 11 years old you were a kid
alex
let it go
people leave
life gets hard
sometimes it's a big [ __ ] sandwich
make it better
be angry at dad miss mom
hell be angry at me
but don't give up
no one gets to tell you what you're
worth
and no one can take your life away
fight
i'm not sure i you have a gift
it's something you don't even understand
you can change the world
make it better
now get up
what get up gabe's night guardian angel
oh attila you lived in college with
three or four boys in one room
i don't know how you did it
well that's handy
hopefully we have something to light it
is that what she's looking for
ah hell yeah
where did you get those again
our lucky match knit
lucky match
oh come on
don't mess this up
okay this be good
we have a little helmet over there too
i don't know if you want they probably
don't want that
okay
let's go find the dragon and then we can
fly out of here
i've got to find all the eggs here and
maybe they'll have some sort of
spaceship
no more ladder
not that i'd be much good at climbing
i wish we could look all the way up
okay there's not going to be much to
look at because she's not moving very
fast
definitely don't want the hat
no it's too late for a hat really isn't
it
oh dead rap
vampires maybe
mine's growing into mines
just like jed said
that was weird sound there i hope it's
not leaking gas anywhere
i'm gonna choose not to read anything
into this
oh is that
i could almost laugh
if it wouldn't hurt so much
safety first
i'm guessing you don't have the strength
to pick this up stuff been down here
ugh
oh no no no no
come on
i can do this
but
um i'm not quite sure
can your eyes adjust
that's exciting
how are you gonna
no what she's using her power
okay
that's something
what her emotion power also
grants her
fight in darkness
or is there something over there the
only lead i've got
there's something over there with an
aura that's
very big and
very angry by the looks of the color
and we're just gonna go to the angry
dragon
or a mob of angry aliens
[Music]
all right boys getting close
held average for life han jed
dig so deep we see where the devil
sleeps
god damn right
this is it
this is what typhon tried to bury
a lot of runoff moisture in this soil
jed we gotta call it this dick is [ __ ]
nothing's [ __ ]
jed we got no pumps running no
my teams have never quitted dick this
deep before
we finish the job
come on clear the tunnel
who's on radio
chad
we gotta move now
there's still men back there they'll
drown yeah and so will we if we don't
get the [ __ ] out make the call jed
god damn it
god damn it
everyone let's go now
must be where typhon blew the charges
[Music]
oh my god
what
how
wait did her dad end up working for jed
somehow
was he one of the hell divers down here
[Music]
dad
come back
did you study the [ __ ]
yeah
chen
you gotta stop man
dad
[ __ ] you john
come back
it's over chad
he's not coming back
i'm sorry
i'm so sorry
did jed know
[Music]
that we were his
daughter and it gave us his son
what
what
okay she miraculously found the exit i'm
happy for her but how
how
she just used her mom's necklace to like
light the way i guess
okay
and she's lucky she could even open that
gate to be honest
yeah screwjed
what we gonna do we gotta be careful
with who sees us
i guess
we can't go back home
we're gonna have to go see
our friends
and
during my time here
i've come to realize what makes haven so
special
it's a flower shop
run by multiple generations
a bar owner who greets every customer by
name
it's a spring festival tradition going
back a hundred years
history
loyalty
pride lawyer these values which define
haven
are the same values that typhon was
built on
and that is why our partnership has been
so successful
it's been my privilege to renew typhon's
commitment to haven
we believe in this community and we're
tremendously excited for its future
thank you diane
i think i speak for all of us when i say
we're eager to make this official
so time to move
like five important things
the whole village
yeah [ __ ] you jeff [ __ ] you jeff [ __ ]
you jen
it's good that everyone else is there
though because that could have gone
badly if it was just yet
[Music]
alex oh my god i'm fine
you are not fine we have to get you to a
doctor what happened to you
[Music]
jed tried to kill me
[Music]
i found out something you need to hear
i'm sorry
[Music]
but
alex you're hurt
[Music]
do you need help we can call an a
typhon's been lying to all of you
and so has jed lucan
[Music]
don't give me that look
what's going on acting like you're all
caring dada
don't pretend you know exactly what's
going on
i was down in the mine last night
i saw what typhon's been hiding for 12
years
jed lucan isn't a hero
that whole story is a lie
jed caused the accident
and then he abandoned seven of his men
he let them drown to save himself
there were pictures of me and gabe down
there in the dirt
because one of those miners
was my father
[Music]
typhon wanted to keep this covered up
in case it jeopardized the vote
[Music]
they're raceless they're ruthless all
they care about is making more money
yeah they'll do whatever it takes to
push this expansion through
so they decided to bury the evidence
and nothing was going to stop that blast
not even the fact that there were four
people up in the mountains
[Music]
that's how gabe was killed
jed knew all along
he covered up the truth about the past
about gabe
and when i found out
as you can see
he tried to kill me too
[Music]
yep
[Music]
why aren't any of you saying anything
wait
don't tell me they own it we don't want
to embarrass you alex
try me
these accusations are
well they're insane oh [ __ ] you and
trying to go into the mine was
obviously a very dangerous very illegal
thing to do
but we all sympathize with your
situation
you've been through so much
gasoline her brother was your only
family wasn't he love that i can only
imagine how much you want an explanation
for his loss
something to give you comfort and
make your life seem less unfair
i know you have a conscience
why don't you just tell the truth
you've been planning your exit from
typhon anyway what
you never signed up for threats or
attempted murder
you hate this
now's your chance to stop
dad
do you have any idea what alex is
talking about
no
i don't
know what to do alex since gabriel that
was father i thought
i don't know
i hoped i could be something of a father
figure to her
oh shut up father's day all i can guess
is
sometimes when we're hurting
the people we lash out at
are the ones who were trying to help
you tried to kill me
how can you stand there and say these
things alex
you're a monster
please
i know this is hard to accept
you all trust him
i did too
but i'm telling the truth
i believe you
of course i do thanks steph let's just
leave screw it screw this little village
oh hell yeah me too
charlotte
i'm
horrified
and shocked and
still processing everything but
i believe you
thank you
ryan
i would like to speak
ducky
this young lady came to haven as a
stranger
but over the last few weeks
she's become one of
us now
her story certainly seems
unlikely if not impossible
but she deserves at least an
investigation of her claims
okay i'll take that i'll tell you take
her seriously
ducky
you're being unhelpful
what alex shut up no not
hey i helped you our mind can play
tricks on us
none of it is your fault
so hard
to admit you need help
but struggling
no
you shouldn't have to go through that
eleanor
i know you're hurting but my situation
is different
we're all worried about you
let us help you
don't worry alex
i got this
oh for [ __ ] sake
i have a usb stick full of recordings
yes pike we went through this yesterday
your superiors closed the case none of
us have time for conspiracies
yeah
they're trying to weasel your way out of
things again huh
i know your game i know don't you test
me jason
so glad you took away his fear
i'm not scared of you anymore
and not you
not typhin all right that's enough
deputy pike do you have some kind of
personal issue with me like hell i do
jason well given that your judgment in
this matter is emotionally compromised
you should probably remove yourself from
the crap if you think you could shut me
up
it concerns me that a voting member of
this council has openly admitted to a
person i'm really sick
of [ __ ] i don't believe getting
ridiculous we're all getting ahead of
ourselves and what's the important
matter here i'm not your lapdog
first thing
such a lovely person as well
nothing like is that
dad
please
come clean
we'll figure it out together
it amazes me
the extent to which she has manipulated
you
come on dad
never in a million years come on
i hate seeing you do this
my own son dad my own goddamn son
stop
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
this is cool
[Music]
i know why you tried to kill me
it's not what you tell yourself
that you thought it was best for haven
this was never about haven at all was it
this was about you
[Music]
i know it's easier
not having to think about the men you
buried
you want to look away and pretend the
people you hurt aren't people
but i won't let you
[Music]
my father worked for you
his name was john
uh
i mean he certainly was not a fighter he
left us
[Music]
he made a lot of mistakes
he wasn't a good father
i think he came here trying to be better
but you killed him
[Music]
and then gabe
my big brother
i wish it was more of a connection
though like i wish he kind of knew
that
the dad got killed and maybe that's why
he sought out gabe and then
tried to
uh
try to like make himself feel better
about
the dad's death by looking after his son
at least something like that it just
seems weird to me that it's all like
massively coincidental but anyway we'll
carry on
um
he was building a family here
doing it his own way
figuring it out as he went along
he was so nervous about it
and so excited
and he brought me here to be part of
that family
[Music]
but he died
because of you
[Music]
okay so he's slowly going from red to
blue so it makes me
sad instead of angry
for so many years i just wanted to
survive
to get through
it even changed me
i started to think about the future
[Music]
bye baggy
oh cool i'm glad there'll be more
explanations soon alice
[Music]
i want to
help people
i want to belong
i want to help people
then she wants to help people i want to
help people
because
it's something i'm good at
knowing i'm good at something
feels [ __ ] great
and you tried to murder me
you would have ended my life
just so you wouldn't have to face the
truth
[Music]
you've forgotten it
it's so cool when her eyes change color
you've plastered over it with another
story
it gets to like read his emotions
[Music]
you
tell yourself
you're a hero
[Music]
a strong leader
sometimes that means making hard choices
[Music]
decisions that could lead to people
dying
a few men could handle that
haven's lucky to have you
[Music]
but that's the lie
if you scrape it away
what do we see
[Music]
guess he's a pawn and a coward
[Music]
let's go for
[Music]
11 years ago you led a group of men to
their deaths
and then you gave your soul to typhon
you let them tell you how awful it would
be for your wife and son to find out
you let them tell you that haven was
more important than the men who died
when it really mattered who you were and
what you stood for
you let typhin decide for you i agree
alice i should feel you trying to go
away
don't
the truth hurts
sometimes it's so awful you think you're
gonna break
but when you come out the other side
and you're whole and free and still
alive
their faces and you'll finally know how
strong you really are
[Music]
i see the truth about you
[Music]
you hate yourself
you hate what you did in the past
you hate what you've done to keep it
secret
and the more you deny that hatred
the worse it grows
[Music]
i know who you are
i've seen the worst parts of you
[Music]
and i forgive
you laughs
[Music]
[Music]
well that was intense
[ __ ]
yeah her powers have gotten much
stronger
[Music]
and the news is still coming in on the
type and mining scandal that has rocked
the western slope town of hayden springs
where a council meeting was the seat for
shocking revelations
local bar owner and council president
jed lucan admitted in a tearful
confession to covering up the deaths of
seven typhon employees as their manager
12 years ago
a recent cover-up which involved the
clandestine and unpermitted explosion to
ford inspections caused the death of
haven local gabe chen last month
mr lucas oh my god has that ever been a
month
awaiting arraignment
we will have plenty more about this
developing story including the
resignation of typhon ceo the market
impact and what it all means for your
drive time commute coming right
for your draft trap commute
i don't care about that
yeah
the silence is worse
i need to get some air
wow she looks nice and healed she's got
a little plant as well now cute
after summoning all my strength and
willpower
i'm now ready
to move
maybe dad deserved everything he got
but i'm still glad we were there with
him in his last moments
they look so cute
okay let's have a look at oh ethan
i have what happened you weren't gonna
mention being a superhero when i texted
yesterday i'm so glad you're safe
okay
okay
[Music]
oh my gosh so many messages yessica
who's that
oh right
damn someone wants her to talk to the
press i guess
steph being cute
[Music]
see what ryan says
growing up my dad was my hero and after
the accident he was the whole town's
hero it was the best feeling in the
world to know the song the same way i
did no one questioned it even when the
strange phone call started the late
nights locking his office when he left
the house but it was all lies
and i know the truth because you showed
it to us let me know if you need help
i'm here
i'll bless him
oh yeah
max max being nice to us that's cute
t-rex you've been through an awful lot
your resilience and courage continues to
sell me i have no doubt that you will
whether there's a front against your
person with the same grace as you
demonstrated to me during our lovely
dance at the spring festival a moment i
will not soon forget cute
ducky
oh cute cute
uh i don't even know what to say my
heart breaks for what you've endured
just remember that ethan and i are here
for you all
thank you
arthur
oh it's another one
when did you learn that your father
listened haven't spoken to word for jed
lucan how did it feel to learn that jed
luke jesus christ this person is
relentless shut up arthur if anyone i'm
gonna speak to yes again okay
cause it's close to jennifer
just let us know when you're okay
brian's freaking out okay we're both
freaking out we just want to make you
safe okay dave
can i call i can't i cannot call
okay fine
do i need a charlotte harmon portrait i
kind of think i need a charlotte harmon
portrait
oh yay she's doing i've got some
continued support for you
the phrase recent events is doing some
work in this post
it never ends
okay so they're doing more
investigations
hmm
the record trade is currently accepting
applications
oh because she's leaving i guess okay
cool
i love this guitar
but if it starts asking me right now
i'm throwing it out the window
yeah i don't think the dad definitely
did not deserve
what he got i am intrigued to know
though
more about how the dad came to be here
it's such a massive coincidence i've
been playing a lot the last excuse to
believe that it is trying to think
things through
but i realize
it's actually the opposite
when i'm playing is the only time i get
to not think
yeah think about jed
or gabe that's why music is not my dad
and what could have been if he'd never
come to this town
most of all
what i don't think about is me
because i've never been good at that
and suddenly
it's the only question that's left
it's a whole fish
i just keep playing
[Music]
and now we stop because we have a game
to play
okay
how about
we
after what i went through
the middle of the ocean might not be so
bad
oh we can't change our clothes again
they just they let us do it so many
times and then all of a sudden they were
like you know what let's just stop this
nonsense it must be rare that a local
paper gets to break out see
this is why i try to only read the art
sections
the following review was far before the
events of the town council meeting the
following day
a surprising newcomer and a three-time
veteran joined together to create a
musical magic under this spring festival
styles on saturday alex chen whose
brother gabe chen long-time bartender at
the blank lantern was killed in a tragic
mining accident
it lit up the crowd with her passionate
vocals and powerful guitar it has been a
long time since i've witnessed a swing
festival crowd dance together with
abandon like that
it was transportive
steph gingrich
and mainstream blah blah held down the
drums for what the duo claimed was their
first time playing together including
even practice sessions color this
reviewer tad skeptical the chemistry was
palpable well
yes our chemistry was very good okay the
game made sure of that
the image of haven springs is a idyllic
refuge and a races of comfort and
civility
blissfully removed but from the tumult
of the outside world was shattered on
sunday in truth that haven never really
existed outside postcards and tourism
board drivel anyway but while we
have weathered troubles and thought
demons in the past we know that this
type of mining stat scandal will leave a
unique scar on the psyche of our small
town not just from what took place
horrible enough as those details are but
from who was involved a young and
beloved bartender of respecting mining
industry up and comer and the town's
most revered patriarch at the center of
it all
jed lukens currently sits in a san
miguel country prison he is said to
fully cooperate with the police and
repentant uh repentant for his actions
he is said to fully cooperative with the
police that doesn't make sense
but the harm he has done to this town to
all of us who knew and trusted him over
the years is just beginning to be
understood still in the face of this
tremendous calamity we say haven will
survive we will
damn okay he's in he's in jail
we still won't have this
[Music]
you ever swing a pic before mr
chan
john and now
but i
i'm a hard worker and i learn fast
and i don't mind long hours
you don't have somebody waiting on you
at home
no sir
well john
guess you're a hell diver now
nothing like being called delusional by
someone you trusted
that one really hurt yeah
chad must have thought he was seeing a
ghost the first time gabe walked in
i'm glad he held on to that would you
like though for whatever it's worth
alex they told me to destroy this jacket
after the accident i couldn't do it
perhaps some part of me knew that one
day i would need to pass it along when
gabe frost stepped into my bar looking
like his father i swore i would one day
return this jacket to him then i swore i
would return it to both of you i think
you know by now what my word is worth i
did not deserve your forgiveness but it
moved me more than i knew was possible i
hope this gift will provide some small
comfort to you in the days ahead
i am glad we forgave him i know if
i don't know it's difficult to do but
i think if someone's remorseful when
they show that i know i guess she was
feeling it
then
i'll never understand exactly what
happened to me down there
but i'll always be grateful
yeah
oh yeah he gave her that matchbox
interview i am now a double victim
first to jed lucan's horrible deception
and now to tyson's attack oh she's
trying
to get out of this but i will fight
tooth and nail to ensure that the real
story is told and my name is cleared
thank you
sounds like diane is angling for a book
deal
hopefully it ends up in the fiction
section where it belongs
i felt very close to ducky after our
dance
i guess he felt the same way even though
it was hard i'm glad i let charlotte
overcome her own anger yeah i think it
gave her the strength to support me
oh wow she might not have supported us
if we had taken away her anger okay this
air was powered by adrenaline that whole
morning
now i'm mostly powered by extra strength
advil
and these
okay let's go upstairs
oh
okay
hey steph alex wait before you say
anything
i have to get this out
okay
what you did at the council meeting
it was the bravest thing i've ever seen
and it made me want to be brave too
so
here it goes
i want to be with you
i don't give a [ __ ] about playing music
or seeing the world
i mean i do but
only if it's with you
and if you'd rather stay here instead
then
i've never had anyone barge in to tell
me that they wanted to be with me before
yeah
how'd it feel someone chose you
oh
how long does she wait to do that
because surely you would have taken a
while for all of her it's given me a lot
to think about things to heal
well good
that was the idea
you know where to find me
good luck chen
thanks steve
oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
i'm so glad that's true steph they i
just i just like them as a couple like
they're cute thank you
all right
just tell me
what
my future
what to do
the night of the spring fest
steph made a strong push for leaving
with her
playing on the road
the excitement of the unknown
of course
that was before all the [ __ ] went down
come on you're the know-it-all
so tell
me actually i do know what you should do
you should stay in haven
you really think so
of course
you finally have a home a job
people who actually like you oh yeah
why would you give that up
that's true
that's true
she's never had that before
then again maybe leaving would be better
what what
don't confuse me you're young you
suddenly have a little money friends
and don't you think it's time to give
this music thing a real shot
no you should definitely leave
oh [ __ ] off
stop it gabe
i don't need the mysterious spirit
[ __ ] right now
i just need
i just need my big brother
i'm sorry
i know
but here's something
[Music]
it's three hours from now
a bus pulls away
you're not on it
and neither is death
[Music]
life goes on
[Music]
you get a job working with steph at the
record store
all those tears of being a music snob
finally pay off
and little by little
time does its thing
[Music]
the apartment starts to feel less like a
museum
and more like a home
thoughts of jed
of typhon
even of me
begin to fade into the background
[Music]
bye rexella thanks for coming
[Music]
are they playing dnz
yeah
[Music]
the rooftop is your stage
you perform every week
to a small but adoring group of fans
maybe while you play you wonder what
could have been
performing for more people in more
cities
sharing your music with the world
[Music]
or maybe you never think about that much
at all
you don't know exactly when it happens
but one day you look around and find
that you have transformed this place
just as much as it has transformed you
and the most extraordinary thing of all
is
just how normal it feels
you don't question it
you don't doubt it
or wonder what might have been
it's your life
the life you fought so hard to have
and for the first time in a long time
you just live
thank you
don't mention it
you really think i'll transform haven
of course you already have
with your gift your
music just by being you
but alex
that doesn't mean you have to stay
you have the potential to do that
anywhere you go
where am i supposed to go
i don't have any other home
that is true
but you didn't have any home before
coming here
and look what happened
the truth is
there's no telling what that version of
your future might be
the only promise
is the adventure
so
what do you think
thanks for following hi girl us
ostrowskis
oh come on game like
you made it
so compelling to stay
how am i supposed to choose seek
adventure
i just feel like
me personally would want to seek
adventure for someone who has never had
this type of family before has just
found it have been through so much with
everyone
and not only that like you know sharla
and her kid and
buying
i just feel like we need to stay at
least for a little bit
to be with them and then i
when
she said that she wanted to help people
what i said that she said she wanted to
help people
not that she wanted to play music so i
don't think
this character
her ambition is to get famous or
anything
i think it's just
to form bonds because she's never had
that and she's got that now so i'm gonna
stay in haven that's my thought process
and i'm choosing this one but it's such
an obvious choice that the game
obviously wants you to pick this i want
to pick the opposite choice but i just
can't do it i just can't do it i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm gonna say
[Music]
i know what i want
we have chosen
you can chat wherever you want uh igor
or strawski
sorry
sorry butchering your name
[Music]
yeah same alice i'm just thinking if you
stay though you can still leave later
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
to the place
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
yeah freaking
happy ending what
there's always some sort of
[Music]
thing that makes me cry loads
[Music]
mountains
[Music]
wait was there only one sound lasagna
[Music]
they don't have any tech designers in
this project
[Music]
i'm very surprised i don't know how many
texts
[Music]
oh that's such a nice image
i've pointed
[Music]
oh my god this weekend
[Music]
how we can implement those ideas with
the systems that we have keeping
performance in mind
[Music]
basically a designer with a more
technical mindset
[Music]
but like they understand the lingo
sorry about that i was just saying yeah
i work as a tech designer so that's why
i was like why are there no text
designers because i thought everyone had
tech designers but um yeah tech design
is basically just designers with with um
who think with a more technical minds
they usually have like some sort of
programming experience they don't have
programs but
um they like talk to the programmers and
designers come up with ideas and then
the tech designers are like these are
the systems we have in place and we
could do it by using x and x and y
and it would
affect performance this way or you know
that's the things that tech design would
think about
um and also like giving tools so like
level designers for instance like
helping their workflow become easier by
giving them tools
um to yeah make the workflow easier be
that like making it place things in the
level easier or making sure that they
have like
right options using certain types of
kits and blah blah blah blah blah anyway
so yeah oh okay
ah
i thought it was going to be like 90 of
people to stay in haven but no it seems
it's quite split so i'm definitely gonna
check out the ending after this on my
own
um tech designers
they don't like need to know a certain
thing i mean if anything it'd be good if
they just know c plus or whatever but it
depends on the project that you're
working on the engine that they're
working with and the engine that they're
working with um would dictate the
language that they're working with so if
they have an idea of that i mean if it's
like unreal engine then blueprints is
fine which is just c plus principles in
a visual
thing uh but it could be like unity
which is obviously c sharp well
obviously sorry i don't mean to i've got
to stop saying obviously because i feel
like sometimes it comes across
concerning um
i hate the gaming professor
yeah maybe they did name tech design
something else but i didn't see anything
that could have been them but not
everyone has them i guess not everyone
uh
okay good so most people forgave jed for
his actions
yes
i just i just had to because you know
it's
just
i think i yeah i don't know i think
everyone deserves forgiveness in some
shape or form you know if they show some
sort of remorse so
yeah
um as claims she learns not to fear her
emotions yeah because that's exactly
what we
did
um some members of the council stood
with alex yes most people got that to be
fair
everyone on the council how could we get
everyone to
maybe if we hadn't told eleanor's
daughter
about but why would you not tell her
about it
i don't know
none of the council members backed alex
four percent got that that would have
been bad
um
alex wanted to help more people in the
future yeah i said that most people said
that only just
oh the other the other amount was to
belong somewhere yeah because they
they're more personal
and then to play music is like okay sure
she probably doesn't want to do that but
that's not you don't that's not your
inner want you know your your inner need
i mean if you
if you want to play music there's
probably a more deep
reason for that it's probably because
you do want to help people or share
something you know
form connections through music there's
probably a deeper reason why you want to
play music to be heard for people and if
it's not for people then it'll be for
yourself to like switch off your
thoughts or
something like that but anyway i think
that's why more people chose
those two
uh
yeah
here we go
here's a new discord link
i need to update it in the description
it's cause someone came in
one stream and like
horrible um so i did yeah disable that
discord link but it seems to be well i
mean of course it will be good now
because no one can come in anymore but
yeah i need to update that discord link
um alex took a moment to reflect yay
alex ryan stood by alex during the vote
oh we did quite good there
about 50 of people alex didn't see ryan
after the vote
did he leave or something
he must have left
alex wasn't ready to forgive ryan
oh
why if he didn't believe her okay
interesting
i wonder what would have changed this
one then
i'm glad i'm glad we got that one that's
a good one
oh don't apologize it's absolutely fine
i want you to get in the discord i do i
do
um
charlotte sided with alex during the
vote yes that made me very happy
um oh you could have had a charlotte
believed alex but couldn't help
oh man about 60 people charlotte turned
her back on alex
is that because they took away her anger
perhaps
eleanor offered to get alex help
yeah what like eleanor come on
excited with alex yeah yeah you
ducky silent with alex yeah yeah yeah
love ducky
uh ryan believed alex yes he did wow
we were in the lower percentage for that
so i really do wonder what
what we did differently to those 69
percent of people
hmm interesting
oh apparently that one's involved too oh
ah let me try
to make another one
um
never expire please
generate a new link copy it
discord link attempt number
two
there you go
um
why not alex started dating yeah and
environment i don't get together steph
stays in haven to be with alex
yeah
okay
that's that
yeah it works
like clockwork
yeah like clockwork you just came in and
literally just finished you didn't even
get to see the option so that's good
because that might have spoiled some
things for you but i will say this
ending um i mean maybe there are
different types of endings but it was a
shock
but it was no way near as sad as the
first two which i'm actually okay with
i'm actually okay with there was a lot
of sadness that happened i felt like
that the pinnacle of sadness happened at
the beginning of this game and then it
was just resolutions
oh my god but we never got that puzzle
resolution
she never completed the puzzle
how did they how did the
how i'm sorry how did they allow that to
happen
this puzzle
no
i'm just thinking did i miss it but i
don't think i did miss it that puzzle
had one piece missing throughout the
whole game
why
i don't know that's really bugging me
why can't they just
allow the puzzle the puzzle on the table
in in the in the flat in in gabe's flat
on the table at the back of the room
it's got a little puzzle on it and it's
got one piece missing it's literally
there from the very start of the game
when you first move into that flat
and i thought oh this is kind of like a
representation of her
trying to like put her life together or
like piece herself back together or
something
i probably massively
thought this and i thought every time i
was in the flat i was like can i find
the missing puzzle piece yet and i
couldn't and then i thought i must be at
the end
but no
that you just never ever got to complete
that puzzle very sad no resolutions to
be had there
how come i get the feeling you're the
only one worried about the puzzle i
can't be the only one austin really
nobody noticed this puzzle
no it probably was just me
i do focus on the tiny tiny things
[Music]
but
the next game we play
because it is spooky month it's gonna be
a spooky game so
no more life is strange this is the end
for now maybe in the future
um but yeah for now
that's that's it done
so thank you so much for
um
watching
i don't know i was trying to say that
thanks for watching
uh i never noticed it no no this is the
puzzle oh i don't know
it just really bugged me okay
all righty
um
oh wavelength is that is that the dlc
okay yeah maybe after spooky month after
some spooky games well we'll uh chill
out a bit by playing this dlc
that sounds quite good
well
i will see you next week also don't
forget if you don't have any halloween
plans
do follow me um so
join the discord
follow me on twitter on instagram all
that good stuff
uh yagman x everywhere because i will be
holding a halloween stream i want it to
be a charity stream as well i haven't
figured out what charity yet but on the
30th of october i'm gonna do a halloween
stream i just need to figure it out
figure out the timings and everything
and then i'll post it up to let you know
so do
keep in touch and yeah look out for that
so
i will see you next thursday at 8 30 pm
on twitch or youtube whichever one you
prefer so
see you then have a lovely day or
evening i'm going to say goodbye to who
i can see in the chat
um
by alice
by austin grubs
by
oh
hi gore
ostroz
ski i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i'm trying
thank you for coming i know this is i
think you said this is your first live
stream and you liked my gregory horror
play through oh i freaking love that
game it's one of my
favorite childhood games so thank you
very much
um goodbye ib196
while on egg
yes while i'm an egg
goodbye
um
sidnator and thanks for coming
goodbye frank
goodbye
[Music]
goodbye clay
goodbye joseph sebastian
goodbye frank
i think i already said that
and goodbye to anyone who i have missed
in the chat and anyone who is watching
and who isn't in the chat as always i
really appreciate you just being here as
well and i just my lights are going off
and i don't really know why
it means that something happened oh
we got a donation thank you so much
roswell
i'm so glad i have my lights here
because they they let me know before the
stream even let me know
sheba dog moves his arm saying goodbye
my um
my restream chat doesn't actually let me
see some emotes and it just like texts
types them out for me in the text so
it's always really interesting to see
her remotes are described thank you very
much roswell i really appreciate it
that's a lovely way to end the stream
and fatal frame yeah we will be playing
that clay
bye john dio as well
okay thank you again roswell thank you
thank you thank you and have a lovely
day or evening i'll see you next week
bye have a good weekend